I'll go impress my name sprayer back
whoa what happened that's me huh Ethan
time it's like anything drunk drunk
pissed off why are you pissed Ethan I uh
is this damn city's too [ __ ] blind to
see what's killing over but Stan is
usually don't have eyes if she had to
speak out it's out there huh I have a
feeling we're about to get better
acquainted
all right whoa where is former agent
Thomas I don't know all right so we're
still on the run I guess but we look a
lot more back whoa what I don't know
what to see why later than [ __ ] but yeah
welcome back the ending
and the ending is pretty much like I cut
it out 30 seconds too far I got a
comment saying oh you don't worry bro
brother gamer continued super long and
then I cut the episode right when the
game ends but it's literally you don't
miss anything banning is just him
looking in the mirror Haneda
hey Soph duck piss off I'm drunk now my
money at all
I'm gonna bite your dick out what why
say that ah [ __ ] I'm playing on an Xbox
suck what are you doing I punch him why
not
this game sucks what ok cool I can shove
it down you do I smell and I just
sweeping garbage all right
what is he telling me players responses
are timed be ready an opportunity can
happen an attack what hey screw ha ha ha
ha ha bad can I do [ __ ] you to barrels I
was meant for barrels that do you man
what rats what yeah uh-huh
Donovan with what bra but the [ __ ] did
you go bring oh okay
squeeze through here special moves it's
squeezing through another project
gabbar's bum the stairs step on the
replay slide 200 you see that [ __ ]
barrels
hahahaha no you don't you know why I
tell you what press to view objectives
alright follow him up the stairs done up
in the gate brother they're gonna fight
some people responded get touch underway
ledge that's how I don't even guy hey we
we don't French me [ __ ] alright
why'd you we got you I'm in need that
[ __ ] [ __ ] stole your ticket
wanker uh-uh it's not gonna be nice to
controls what else
hey come say that to my face yeah that's
right what I wouldn't [ __ ] with a guy
like I don't know Oh No all of you oh no
fist come back it's time to put a fist
up to my brother oh oh oh oh say happy
birthday say hey I'm to Jennifer burger
Jennifer Rocha
alright anyone else anyone else oh you
want to say howdy birthday and Jennifer
oh you keep your [ __ ] bro
you can do [ __ ] bro look I do [ __ ] Bob
stay down when I say stay down
[ __ ] [ __ ] fist your ass I block
with both okay I guess I was what I was
doing before
all right [ __ ] oh don't give me that
[ __ ]
stay down stay down stop shaking stop
shaking stop shaking stop shaking I tell
you stop shaking you better stop shaking
say hi to Jennifer
ah [ __ ] stay why don't you die like a
bow
are you suck is that all you got you're
pathetic
my god alright I guess I gotta block it
on that all you got let's go for penis
punch punch your dick benefit shut up
all right
one-two combo perform two alternative
jabs and then attack
what okay perform to our channel JJ
pitch what perform a one-two combo one
ona ona yes tonight
Quadra wanted to come back did I do it
did I do it
I don't think blockage run - ow - stop
hitting me you [ __ ] stop oh I did it
all right what is this parry counter
combo parry an incoming attack and then
do a quick jab all right so I parry and
then punching bam bam
hey that's how I roll that's how I get
down lady oh hell yeah hell yeah that's
how I roll whoo million [ __ ] it's like a
tutorial episode holy [ __ ] come on
enough tutorial much spooks that's what
I say exit now let's [ __ ] talk this
game
alright alright it's blankie all right
does that mean we'll see prepare again
ha
go ahead take it off ah take him up
block it head Oh dead dirtbag in and
dumped oh that's how I roll punch it
blockage oh you're holding me back gimme
repair give me back my pen give me back
my back I bet Madge ever fed me back I
know y'all hey give it back oh my god I
mean you look so good in out oh no dad
no I don't want to have mopped my ass
please I'm not ready I don't have fun
okay okay what what what - Farooq Iran
the super duper well-prepared still here
and the game say I guess that's good
what ah I guess we go over here nah I
don't [ __ ] know wait did the door
just open cool TV repay oh that's enough
of that you find reception grab an
antenna and slowly what [ __ ] it give me
back your fare grab antenna why what's
the point of this alright ignoring that
calls man horn was foolish you know it
why
forget the past okay still we destroyed
you why did you do it
find him like you he knows about are you
like a massive all right trust you whoa
look bro dun dun see ya yes we're open
go smack all the teeth oh wow
hello going in here alright alright no
no no dogs dogs oh yeah
what a it Joanne stick what is this
alright we're going up rose god I step
it TV I'm supposed to just done 10 now
am I [ __ ] it I'll do it
alright show me what you got you know
better than those that just come in this
yeah I hate them they're insane I'm
talking there's no reasoning just
killing
huh hey bro your turn your to knee Abra
all right
guess he was in a bro after all I get
the feeling I have to watch that to open
that [ __ ] door son of a [ __ ] you
know better than to just come in this
release me what Canyon stain scum uh-huh
there's no talking no reasoning not
killing kill first would be a running
horse
okay I'm pretty sure they'd write that
damn Oh son of a [ __ ] I go back then
[ __ ] do you want from me
wait did I throw P back can't throw
prepare Billy you have to go down silly
man all right fine prepare but I don't
want to go down what
No why would you laugh about that all
right I got you
no stay down ow son Nicky Oh [ __ ] stay
down block it's true
oh that's right Oh what is this what
what continue chasing banner you yellow
what are you doing [ __ ] off hey down
penetration all right we're good we are
so good into that [ __ ] give it I get it
why can't I use it huh [ __ ]
I guess we're going here
or no but where the hell are we going
then to the game you don't know how to
roll all right let's see what he says I
might listen this douche
alright there we go the city is full of
these sonic devices Oh sounds like a
conspiracy from your vagina - fine got
it well I did it [ __ ] better than
that alright fine that one now at
gasolina but about all right here's the
door open this door block [ __ ] sighs
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] creepy tell this game
buddy you know I don't throw TVs stop
stop what awaits a money man
stop not the toilet oh that's - all
right fine then find then hope you're
happy
hope you're happy stop not again you had
enough you're grounded mister
right you've got so grounded I'm gonna
your ninth even gonna chase after you ha
ha hi check ya blockage penis punch it
bad but slapping is the best way to kill
someone
their ass alright we get done what are
you doing
no block me what is this retweet combos
alright I'm fine I'm fine don't worry
about me brother blockage not sure but
slab edge blockage
hey face what what Ellie I do I was like
don't block my epic mouth
yeah die die
Oh taste it taste it taste it taste it
Lucy Jason penis punch a penis punch
left ball rice ball critical ball punch
want to just die oh [ __ ] you're annoying
all right and that's how I roll
thank you very much all right
environment they'll kill come on stop
teaching me what are you doing here
sorry to interrupt your poo time hey
take a [ __ ] and then we'll fight no
penis punch famous punch right punch
hey this punch penis punch oh that's
right that's right
okay okay okay okay ha truck truck oh
how should we kill him oh ha ha ha
down the toilet bit no come on please
let me kill him in the toilet
why should I click a [ __ ] all right uh
but the toilet was a good idea where do
you want to die brah I don't know the TV
it's like way too good no okay
I don't know how you want to die okay
stop this it's really awkward you want
to make out
let's make out is that a nose piercing
ah okay I guess the TV what's the way to
go did I get an achievement
it looks really up are you still alive I
don't get it I don't get it I'm getting
what are you doing stop moving aren't
you dead should be fixed dead babies
always make them react it's like tech
McCready
tell your wash pet shut up not doing
that not gay
all right all right here we got ya
freakin pick step out away no no what I
do but I don't she'll just you sure sure
sure sure sure sure
I don't wanna fight you all right fine
Rams right right Josh and I met at a
place right never left nipple
mm ah twist that's how I roll penis
punch name special pin spice penis punch
finish punch scene is fine finish
wait your penis is in the back all right
it's time to go over here climb through
that [ __ ] and that's save right there
how's it going it's fun hey wait hey oh
yeah ah hey ah goddamn that [ __ ]
senile [ __ ] you never knew this what
he's doing alright friends episode yeah
but like everybody enjoyed want to see
more of a condom and subscribe got rich
and I'll see you next episode oh boy my
big please leave a like as I frickin
well you don't have to but it took me
forever to set this up so hope it's
worth it there are these stupid
headphones too anyway that's that sounds
right
alright let us sleep in the milk just
like he always wanted
that's right extreme develop